verity of this coveted surge can clearly
be seen in america's hospitals where the
average number of covert patients is now
the highest it has been since last
winter the danger is now complicating
people's decisions about whether to
travel this labor day weekend earlier
this week the cdc advised those who are
not vaccinated to not travel our era
barnett spoke to travelers though who
are weighing the odds
the barbecues and beach trips that
typically wrap up the summer just might
be busted this year if you are
unvaccinated
we would recommend not traveling that
was the moment this week when cdc
director dr rochelle wolenski urged the
unvaccinated to stay home and the rest
of us to reconsider people need to take
their own these risks into their own
consideration as they think about
traveling we were going to
do a desert sunrise yoga zoom guided
self-care coach jenkin finkel who is
vaccinated just canceled her joshua tree
california plans after her own
recalculation her friend asked are you
going to feel comfortable if you go
and when i really thought about that my
answer was no
plenty of americans agree this holiday
weekend none of the major airlines
expect to reach pre-pandemic traffic
united forecasts a 23 percent drop
meanwhile airfare spending is down 33
percent this month compared to the same
time in 2019
you have a perfect storm here peter
greenberg says there are multiple
reasons for the declines about one-third
of it is seasonal and expected
one-third of his delta and one-third of
it is the european union proposing new
restrictions on american travelers
earlier this week the u.s was removed
from the eu's safe list which means
quarantine and testing requirements are
more likely for americans if you're
still scared don't just don't go out
stay home back here in the u.s ariana
vermillion and millions of others are
sticking with their holiday travel plans
we've been waiting for this trip for a
long time because we had to cancel last
year while gerfinkel feels like
scrapping an itinerary should come with
no shame you know this is the right
thing for you to do to feel safe and
protect yourself and protect others for
cbs this morning errol barnett
washington
did you catch the name in that piece of
the woman jinka garfinkel
best names i've heard very cool on tv i
also caught the fact she's walking away
from what looks like a wonderful trip to
joshua tree i see that's a decision a
lot of people are making exactly see
that be careful if you're out there
traveling this labor day weekend